foreign
[Music]
yeah damn I forgot I've got that as well
God that made me laugh I'm black 15 male
that goes to a school full of Whites by
the way I'm in year 10. so there's this
boy dies in year 11. they used to go to
my old school black boy
once we both found out we once we both
found that out we became friends and
long story short I ended up signing him
off
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
bro yo
the escalated it did it did wow okay
Carry On yeah wait
um I ended up seeing him off it's not
that I like him or anything and we are
still friends that chat the same before
it happened huh and we're still friends
and we chat the same before it happened
and everything stayed the same
now there's this one black girl that I'm
so called friends with uh let's call her
Gemma that's just too much nobody can
stand her she's loud for no reason draws
attention to herself Etc
ever since she joined the school she's
been going back to back with the guys in
the school on the first day she said she
would give head to two boys in our year
since then she's been pushing herself
into them and lying on their name for
example
one of my close male friends got stuck
in the middle with her she lied saying
that he grabbed her bum
uh when what really happened is that she
tried to force him to grab her bomb
so yeah so today the day I'm writing
this she said that the boy I gave bris
to three times
I don't know why but that was the last
straw
busy
that's the that's the new one
I don't want to chat to her no more
we're on half term so I don't have to
see her for a week am I the answer for
wants to cut her off when I S when there
is a slight chance she could be telling
the truth
um and that's it let me let me know does
he chat to her for any other reason the
fact that she's black maybe not because
he's yeah because he's not said a single
positive word about this entire time
then again it's we've not we don't know
his account
his account of the girl yeah this is a
girl so this is a girl saying you're
going up I thought it was a guy though
this is when you said I ended up sucking
did you think it was a guy yeah I
thought the exact same thing oh he said
male at the start 15 male 15 female did
you hear mail oh you said male I've
wrote yeah bro you said mail yeah my bad
this whole time that's what I said long
story short
15 female goes to school full of whites
um she's in year 10 there's another
black boy in year 11. long story short
she sucked him off
um they're not really friends or
anything
um it's just because they happen to have
good chat or whatever yeah yeah yeah
yeah uh another black girl another black
girl drawing who their who she's friends
with
um but nobody could really stand her
she's too loud and blah blah blah and
she lies on people's names
um she said the first day that she
apparently gave head to two other boys
we don't know if it's true or not and
she's um also saying that she that the
boy she gave risk to bang that three
times banged this other girl three times
when we but again we don't know yeah
[Music]
he gets considering there's a slight
chance she might be telling the truth
I'll cut her off anyway even if she's in
a troops she sounds hectic sounds hectic
and toxic she sounds like she wants to
be center of attention considering she
is one of three maybe black people yeah
I don't see anything positive come from
this friendship yeah so I would just cut
it yeah yeah it's also one of the it's
crazy because the way my brain works is
like
this is like me and girls territory and
you're the only two black girls in the
school so if you're not Brethren yeah
there's going to be allies for one like
yeah yeah
the Optics looks mad race Wars yeah the
Optics looks man and no one else black
is backing you do you know how mad that
is 100 yeah unless a new new black
person comes in yeah
for that attention yeah yeah yeah that's
all a lot it is long so I can see the
social pressure to be her Brethren yeah
yeah she's
grabbing man's hand and making a squeeze
our body and then run the mouse and he
squeeze my seat squeeze Moss I have to
cut you off yeah I have to that's um
that's scary that's scary I wouldn't
it's weird because do you know what's
great it's weird reading like Secondary
School dilemmas as a 32 year old man oh
100 because it makes me feel like what
are you man do it literally focus on
your education do you know what I mean
what do you mean
exactly you're only a 10. bro chill out
chill out bro if I was a 15 year old you
wow wow that's my dream
110 that is my dream do you think for a
second bearing in mind I barely care
what she looks like yeah yeah if one of
the black girls in school was grips in
my house and squeeze my
squeezing it it's fitting yeah it would
even fold through my fingers
in it and then she can run around until
she won she can say what she I'll say
you forced me facts bro but yeah um that
whole the whole Optics of it is is nuts
yeah it's [__] crazy but no just cut
off brush your sounds toxic yeah let me
get you in trouble bro yeah and if she
finds out that you bruised up my math
yeah she's gonna run him after everyone
so yeah you need to cut her off keep
that close and cut her off man
um and anyway guys we're gonna lock it
there thank you very very much that was
a pink episode and uh love love as
always
[Music]
foreign